we got this tweet from Mario novel he
says breaking CNN on Trump's exoneration
quote it is regardless devastating to
the FBI and to a degree it does
exonerate Donald Trump Jake Tapper he
says is CNN becoming less biased will
other major media fellows certainly play
this clip of Jake Tapper for you
regardless the report is now here it has
dropped and it might not have produced
everything of what some Republicans vote
for it is regardless devastating to the
FBI and to a degree it does exonerate
Donald Trump who would agree
they're still so scared they're still so
scared of liberals they can't just say
Trump did not collude with Russia he
says to a degree it proves he didn't
clue with Russia no it literally proves
he didn't collude with Russia
I want this to be true so badly exactly
it no it does not exonerate Trump to a
degree Trump was exonerated about all of
this long ago what it does to a degree
is indict you and everyone else in the
media who is parroting this nonsense and
the the mainstream media language around
this is so funny to me AP put out this
this article about it and said the
findings aren't flattering for the FBI
like like it's not looking good we don't
want to say anything but it's not great
and they say like uh that the best game
was done without was done without uh
without adequate bias and routinely they
routinely ignored or rationalized
evidence that undercut the premise so
the whole time they were aware that this
was not worth it and they were like but
we're gonna keep going literally what
happened was they said they said Trump
has a p-tape and we said care to
elaborate further and they said no do
you guys remember the Huffington Post
story about somewhere some video of
trump doing something yes I saw that
that was killing me that was killing me
uh but no that's literally what happened
right and they're never gonna admit they
were wrong as I said you know it's it's
just one scam after another move on
doesn't matter doesn't matter how many
times they're proven wrong does not
matter how here's the here's the story
from 2018 the hunt for every Trump
reporter's white whale the elevator tape
it says there it was some 1500 words
into a story published in The Daily
Beast the infamous Donald Trump elevator
tape not the tape itself but the first
reference the bombshell tape of trump in
an elevator what is the the Walsh
journal the AP and others had Chase if
it hit that may not even exist a certain
contingent of journalists who'd spent
months searching for something worth
publishing all that really mattered was
the formal unveiling of the tape rumor
to the public it was basically nothing a
story about literally nothing
and they all chased after it the famous
quote was that was the Tweet where it
was like somewhere something exists what
it is we don't know what it's about not
sure but Trump was there we believe it
Trump took the elevators not taking the
stairs it's not healthy this is a real
scandal
they were desperate to find anything
they were desperate to find it and look
we know well it was it was very
difficult to attack Trump on the basis
of his policies because
Alvin and both tweeted a tape might
exist of trump doing something in an
elevator though exactly where that
somewhere is and what that something
might be no one in media can say that's
because known in media seems to have
seen the tape or is even confident it
exists what what does that mean they
were they were writing articles about
this imagine somebody walks into The
Newsroom and they're like I got huge
news I just want like Trump may have
been an elevator at some point with a
camera doing something I don't know what
he did when he did it or why it was
filmed and they're like whoa can we find
that tape yes I just want this to have
been someone on his campaign who's like
I know one liberal journalist I'm gonna
start this rumor and just see where it
goes and they read these tweets and
they're like I started that they can't
tell anyone because somewhere there's a
video of Donald Trump well they're like
they're they're children it's
embarrassing it is embarrassing that a
news Outlet would publish that yeah
something so you know it happens
somewhere this is literally when you
were in third grade and didn't read the
book and then you got called in front of
the class to do your book report you're
like yeah something happened when
somewhere they were like I got big news
a video
may exist if Sheamus Coughlin no no
doing something now what he was doing I
don't know where it happened I'm not so
sure but a video exists of Shame is
doing something somewhere in fact quite
literally what you're watching right now
is a video of Sheamus doing something
somewhere it's not bad it's just
literally Sheamus talking about politics
but plausible but um imagine this
imagine this you could literally play
the the media was so insane
I could I could claim there is a
shocking video of Sheamus Coughlin doing
something somewhere and then everyone's
like whoa I wonder what it could be and
they imagine Sheamus like juggling
bowling pins or skydiving who knows when
in reality I'm referring to Tim guest
Ira my biggest scandals were juggling
bowling pins we didn't say it was a
scandal we just said you're doing
something oh exactly and then everyone
turns into a scandal by imagining the
craziest thing yes it really it really
is bizarre as I guess I'm technically a
journalist and it pains me to say that
because that's a rough one I know
whenever you're meeting new people and
I'm introducing myself like what do you
do I'm like I'm a journalist I'm sorry
I'm not gonna like smear you
um but it really is bizarre to me right
like running with a story like that when
there's really nothing to report and I
think what we're gonna see start to kind
of unfold which obviously we all know
here but obviously the hunter Biden hard
drive story in terms of the collusion
with big Tech and the FBI the CIA that
letter I think that really proves that
there is sort of a merger really I'd
call it an axis of Evil between these
assets of the deep State and Tech
platforms but I think the third
component to that really is the
mainstream media and I think we've
always known they've laundered talking
points on behalf of the federal
government but I think this case again
yes it's Vindication yes we know Trump
didn't collude with Russia but this is
like clear and controvertible evidence
that I don't think we typically get to
see it so plain front and center at
least you know us mere American people
us mere mortals us non-elites
um so I think we're going to start to
see just like that Hunter Biden story
has sort of started to unfurl and you
get good tidbits every now and then I
think there's going to be a lot more
coming out about how the media has
really just taken whether it's fbic you
name it their talking points and just
repeated them mindlessly I got I got
good news though take a look at this
based CNN's ratings are now below
Newsmax amazing Newsmax has surpassed
CNN look at this 8 P.M 9 pm news max is
like yes we knew we could do it meeting
CNN I mean to be fair
CNN's been collapsing but look Newsmax
is considered more conservative right
they get smeared and attacked by the
corporate press and now they're so
they're displacing them CNN tried to
play dirty games and now they will cease
to exist but have you considered that
somewhere someone might have done
something in CNN may possibly have some
of that footage also they're sorry yeah
they're actually I'm sorry I can't
confirm sorry there isn't there is a
video of Anderson Cooper doing Anderson
Cooper doing something somewhere well
the thing is I'm not sure and where it
is I don't know but the video does exist
and if we can find it oh boy oh that'll
be really bad it'll be really bad let's
write 27 articles about it for the next
three years every day the white whale a
video that no one knows anything like do
you know how many videos of trump in an
elevator there are probably 17 000 yeah
because all of these different Casino
elevators have uh have have cameras most
big uh high security like high rises and
penhouses have cameras every time Trump
got in an elevator there's a video of
him in an elevator doing something oh I
just want to know how many journalists
spent hours watching like leaked or like
footage they finagled away from someone
it's Trump just like standing in the
elevator like any second now he's gonna
do something crazy like there there's no
commitment to truth there's no
commitment to reality or honesty I got I
mean look I think I'm a cartoonist I
read jokes and I do political commentary
I'm not a journalist not not anything of
the sort I ca and I given my state in
life as someone who makes jokes I could
never imagine grabbing a story like that
and repeating that to people because you
got to be responsible with your platform
I think this is like the two-sided
nature of Journalism today right like
they believe there is a reality that
they live in and they are here to
disprove your reality they don't believe
we all live in a common shared reality
they believe that if they can create
enough evidence of their own belief
system you have to admit that their
worldview is right and you have to
conform to it I think that's the the
strange thing about so much of
essentially content creation that gets
passed off as journalism today it's
about arguing that the things you
believe are wrong because my world view
is is necessitated on the fact that the
these things I know to be true that
Trump is evil be colluded with Russia
and that if we vote for him the
country's falling apart and in reality
even if you don't like everything Trump
does he is not this like
you know terrible person that should
send you into hysterics well yeah I mean
none of these journalists or journalists
like 98 of the people who call
themselves journalists or political
commentators or their bloggers or
something like that they write opinion
pieces or they give you your perspective
about something on television literally
I'm telling you they're real journalists
they're real journalists and you're not
and this is the thing I I am saying this
and I actually am willing to stand by
this there there is a large percentage
of the people who call themselves
journalists who minus like running a
business and producing animation do kind
of the same thing I do which is read
articles learn about the issues do a bit
of research and then comment on them
they don't actually go investigate
issues on the ground they don't do
interviews with people they don't try to
find the truth uh and like granted I do
try to find the truth so that's one
difference but they will just read
things online on like their news feed or
maybe they have someone who looks at
articles for them and they'll start
commenting on it but they're not like
investigating the way you want a
journalist to they're just reading
things so they can give an opinion about
it well I think the cherry pick facts so
that they can serve their own reality
and that's the only way to describe it
they will say well we think there's a
video of trump so therefore he's a
suspicious character so therefore you
should trust us when we say he did all
of these things wrong I think they are
completely uh biased to or they're
completely blind to their own bias
because it's so deeply embedded in their
worldview do you think that like yeah
you know what I'm actually going to
Google this right now I want to see like
what the bare minimum is for referring
to yourself as a journalist there's
nothing there's nothing so I could just
amateur because you know I like I did go
to the March for Life for for Tim cast
and interview people like General
journalists I mean I interviewed people
about why they were at the March for
Life so I guess I'm a journalist
and I'm going to add journalists to it
right now I think there used to be a
standard right like a journalist is
different than a reporter which is
different than a writer that's just
different than a columnist but now it's
a blanket term for anyone who pushes who
who pushes that disinformation which is
information or publishes something that
resembles news news adjacent we might
call it I'm gonna so I'm adding
journalists to my bio and in fact I'm
adding journalists first and foremost
oh I don't have enough words left all
right I'm just gonna put journalist in
my bio there boom it's done yeah I'm
literally a journalist now where's my
blue check mark I don't know I I think
you have to create one I think you can
buy one blue check mark something you
just buy I know now you just buy it I
should have done some some journalism on
that hold on don't be too hard on
yourself search is surge the only
non-journalist here right now that's so
important I'm currently doing journalism
right now I'm always doing journalism
just by being alive I do no I'm just
kidding I I think that's the hard thing
we have moved uh one of the benefits of
the digital age is how quickly we can
get new information out there and the
new formats that we get to discuss news
and have commentary I mean this podcast
exists essentially like four different
opinion writers talking at the same time
giving your opinion as opposed to
reading four different opinion columns
written around the same times about an
issue and that's more fun on the other
hand we have
um I think sort of
grade the classifications of news media
because anyone can be a journalist and
also no one truly has any journalistic
ethics or obligations I mean I think
people do I don't want to be too hard on
all reporters there are some great
journalists who do fantastic work but
like I don't think you should just be
like I'm out here with my cell phone
recording the street therefore I'm a
journalist unless you are putting some
effort in you're researching you're
trying to find the truth you're talking
to people whose opinion you don't like I
think that's what bothers me the most so
many people go into this sphere just to
talk to people who they like themselves
and uh who produce talking points
similar to the ones they would produce
if they were the one being interviewed I
feel like you can really cross Supply
that critique to virtually every
industry in America in the sense of this
whole refrain of you know trust the
experts right the expert journalists at
the New York Times and the CNN cnns and
the Washington posts of the world
they're actually not our intellectual
betters and superiors and I think the
House of Cards Right This ability to
enforce narratives like the Russia
collusion hoax like rests on this sort
of worshiping this idea that oh because
you work for the New York Times and you
have journalists in your bio and you
have a blue check mark we must believe
what you say because you're from the
federal government and you're telling us
how to mitigate a pandemic we must
listen to you and what you're saying and
I I think it's sort of they just want
the American people again who are so
dumb because they see an article on
Facebook they're just going to start
supporting some candidate
um but I really think they just want us
to blindly
put our faith in every aspect of our
life right over our bodies what we
believe what we think what we eat you
name it
um into our you know intellectual
superiors into this Elite ruling class
and I think frankly that was what covet
proved that this Elite ruling class that
is so smart and Joe Biden who you know
that class of people used to mock I
always thought they'd always say oh
Donald Trump made a fool of America on
the world stage and I always like this
concept of the world stage like they
care so much with their you know
globalist Brethren think of them and
what America looks like but then you
take a step back and you're like okay
well even if I'm gonna run with that
Paradigm uh Joe Biden has made us look
like a complete idiot and just a dismal
failure on the world's stage I just I
just want to point out as you all were
talking I was I was doing journalism
I found the footage this is a still
image Donald Trump in the elevator look
how shocked everyone is oh my God
they're they're shocking uh they're
they're so surprised that his behavior
As Trump is is yelling about something
that is so so shocking this footage that
I can't even describe to you what
actually happened in that elevator trust
me I've seen it that is legitimately one
of my favorite one of my favorites of
course this is an art an AI generated
image of Donald Trump in an elevator I
just typed it into my journey
AI generated journalism
one of my favorite things you're
mentioning a lot of things they were
saying about Trump when they had an
anonymous source reporting that Trump
said something completely insane on
Veterans Day like I frankly hate all
veterans it was the most absurd nonsense
in the world like okay he didn't say
this Anna was from an anonymous source I
I couldn't help but laugh because you
know an anonymous source only works if
you're a trustworthy person yeah right
if there's any reason to trust you I
have seen the stories that you guys tell
when you have a named source so no I
don't trust your Anonymous sources and
frankly I think you probably made it up
yourself well and theoretically if you
had Professional Standards you'd call
the Trump White House or campaign
wherever we were in the timeline and say
hey do you care to comment on this we're
gonna run with this story you should
have a chance to respond that's supposed
to be ethical but they probably won't
and even if they do they'll say you know
the Trump campaign categorically denied
this while they shook in their boots
because they're so scared of our amazing
anonymous source but we can't tell you
anything about it's real trust us I
think that it was important to
acknowledge that this does happen in all
walks of life that's a really good point
I think there are so many institutions
that people point to when they want to
use authority to back up their arguments
I mean we see this a lot I I I'm loath
to bring it up because I know we talk
about a lot but um with the transgender
ideology movement people point to the
American Association of Pediatrics and
say well they say there are certain
things you are supposed to do they'll
point to all kinds of medical
establishments I think we have to look
back and say why do we trust these
institutions some of them may do good
work I don't know but you should look
into the institutions who's on the board
how do they assemble themselves are they
elected you have to have a certain
qualification what is their mission
statement if you just throw out the name
like this is the authority then you are
either a trying to hide the bias or B
you are not aware of the bias which in
and of itself is dangerous if you're
putting yourself in a position where
you're supposed to be giving out solid
information dude mid journey is crazy it
is wild I just I got another one you're
doing some real journalism tonight I'm
tweeting another one let me uh let me
try and let me try and pull it up for
you so Natalie personally he's a
journalist I've never used an anonymous
source have you ever
I'm trying to think if I've actually
ever unironically used it or not you
know most of my reporting well I guess
either comes from the hunter Biden hard
drive or publicly available data that
the mainstream media won't report on
when it comes to Chinese Communist Party
infiltration because usually I'm
reporting on how the mainstream media is
compromised by the Chinese Communist
party it's a very good niche market I've
found
um but no it is it is weird it really is
funny though and like you guys are
saying like people I think for the most
part hate journalists like I get that
whenever I'm introducing myself to
people and telling them what I do for
work I have never had a positive
interaction with someone then when they
find out that I'm technically like not
really a journalist because it's Steve
Bandon and he's great then they're like
oh you're normal you're like not one of
them but people hate journalists yeah I
didn't I didn't realize but my
experience is I don't know if you've
ever had this happen but if you talk to
someone who is like Progressive or left
and who is a journalist and they like
proudly introduce themselves as a
journalist like they are the bearers of
truth I find this very fascinating like
it is definitely a cultural shift some
people do not trust the media and for
good reason but there are some people
who wear it as a badge of honor and that
is also worrisome yes and of course I
feel like we can't we have to give an
honorable mention to the like fact
Checkers of the world and the Media
Matters the media Watchdog types because
they're obviously in on the same grift
but no they call they attack me all the
time for working with Steve saying that
I'm not actually an investigative
reporter it's like fine then point to
one of my stories true prove it right
I've never been sued I've never
published or printed anything incorrect
frankly a lot of my investigations have
led to people wiping their Twitter
accounts getting fired getting removed
from boards so the evidence is there
right there's obviously action occurring
from my reporting so it's just I think
you know you brought up the transgender
movement a lot of this just I think has
to also just do with like distorting
words right like journalists doesn't
mean what it used to mean because
definitions don't really they're not
rooted in reality because everyone can
have different really versions of
reality and that's of course Amplified
by the fact that if you turn on CNN and
say oh to a degree well what what does
that mean you know it's it's not even
double speak it's just it's a whole
different language thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time